it was the first public debate between
the two front-runners in Brazil's
presidential election
six candidates were on the stage but all
eyes were on incumbent right-wing
president
and left-wing former leader Louisiana
Silva
together they have more than 70 percent
of the votes Lula who governed Brazil
from 2003 to 2010 and is leading the
polls blame bolsonaro for the country's
rise in poverty
the country I left is a country that
people miss it was a country of
employment it was a country where people
had the right to live with dignity with
their heads held up and this country
will return
bolsonaro attack Lula accusing him of
leading a political corruption Scandal
involving Brazil's state-run Oil Company
petrobras it was corruption president
Lula you want to come back what for to
keep doing the same thing at petrobrass
Lula spent 19 months in prison before
bribery convictions against him were
annulled putting him back on Brazil's
political scene
who is trying to appeal to Women Voters
denied misogynistic claims against him
but during the debate he attacked a
female journalist who criticized his
response to the covid-19 pandemic
Vera you sleep thinking about me you're
a disgrace to journalism analysts say
both front-runners did poorly on Sunday
but that will unlikely influence the
outcome of this unprecedented election
they are totally different from other
elections in Brazil because you have an
incumbent president fighting in a former
president
and that that has never happened in
Brazilian history
secondly no president incumbent
president has started the campaign in
its advantage
regarding his opponent Taxi Driver
Carlos Costa says the debate did not
change his mind
I voted for bolsonaro in 2018 because I
was sick of corrupt governments I'll
vote for him again
Santos says she supported Lula and still
does
I would prefer a third opinion between
Lula and bolsonaro but since we have
none I'll vote for Lula because I know
his government has favored the poor and
we are now struggling to put food on the
table bolsonaro's trailing Lula in all
of the polls both men will have to win
more than half of the valid votes cast
to be elected president during the first
round on October 2nd if not the election
will go to a runoff on October 30th
Monica and akiv Al Jazeera Rio de
Janeiro